in these nine new players for the Lakers
Lakers for threes already
LeBron's got the Bell in the middle it
goes for Damian puts on the brakes and
hits the deck tried the punch Green was
there an amazing block and don't feel
bad Sam and I've been in this same
situation when you think it's wide open
and the door shuts
and there's LeBron James helping make
some misses they gotta push the basket
get a chance here for Davis Green the
offensive board
caldwell-pope it sounds
[Applause]
knew about a brownie LeBlanc gets held
up by Zeller morant that's good bounce
he's known as the guy that chases the
day boom for the rundown solid he'll
says I got old where'd he come from you
know where he came from out of the
rafters essence dirts been here their
thesis said we're going to get into our
flow Brunson gets hot
Mariana meds gets stripped he can drive
right drive left nice crossover but
James on the recovery picked the pocket
of right of them Arianna [ __ ] called on
the fish Lakers have you extended back
to the end of the second on a 12o run a
chance to tie or take the lead here
Bradley ties it and one that sparks a
timeout from Rick Carlisle six point
Dallas lead James on the steal porzingis
at it stripped gets it back porzingis
lost it again and this time James
controls it James all the way for this
LeBron James has put the Lakers in front
for an intensity on that end that I've
seen in a long time I mean the ball
comes loose yes he's in a great position
but end to end this is still a bad man
and his hit big Nullah
[Music]
15 of 30 as DeRosa
the block by James
[Music]
Bonnie had vertigo inside the turnover
James
they've hit 19 of 22 from the free-throw
line 11 point edge there
the Lakers are shooting 49% to the floor
but the Spurs turn it over to start the
opening possession
Kobe white has 11 marketed marketing
with LeBron just trying to bustle
apartment door where to go block by
LeBron getting the charges get another
look at the defense brother bran it
didn't go for the face got a block shot
and then converts that into this play
where he's going to the line
there's shoot two